[Music]
[Music]
well i think the pandemic ranks
obviously
hugely on everybody's minds
and i think what's unusual about the
pandemic is that it has been obviously
first and foremost um it's a you know
it's a medical
issue in economic terms it's both a
demand and a supply shock as in it's
affected um obviously all of our lives
and that's the demand side of the
economy it's also been hugely disruptive
to the supply side if we think about
borders having closed so in my book the
great economist how their ideas can help
us today
i look at the past 250 years really
since the industrial revolution and
there have been a number of crises
obviously financial crises of 10 years
ago comes to mind um but having a
pandemic
generate a crisis recession
that's actually fairly unusual on a
global basis in fact the spanish flu of
1918 is really the only comparable one
and i think that probably um you know
just gives a sense of how unusual um
this time is
[Music]
well there's a lot of i think different
ideas we can glean from a great
economist um you know over uh the past
couple of centuries or so so just help
us think through the kinds of policies
that are needed uh to cushion um you
know the economic impact um of this
pandemic so for instance
if we look at
how
just how devastating it's been for a lot
of people's livelihoods this idea of
using furlough schemes
income support to support viable
businesses keeping people attached uh to
the labor force helping them um you know
just maintain employment even though
there's been this massive demand shock a
lot of those ideas can be traced to the
1930s so this is the era of the
keynesian revolution john maynard keynes
and
some of his disciples like john john
robinson they really focused on
how
the classical economist so this is
people who came before them people like
david ricardo
didn't think
i think enough about how you get the
economy back to full employment to get
to people back on their feet so the
keynesian revolution the 1930s was
predominantly aimed at trying to cushion
um and get
the uk economy back after the the great
depression by focusing on employment by
focusing on how government can invest
in order uh to try and just get the
economy back to where it was
more quickly and that's where also where
you get that very well known saying by
keynes
you know in the long run we're all dead
and so waiting for the economy to write
itself which was the classical economic
approach um he thought
probably wasn't enough
[Music]
so a lot of the criticism
of the keynesian approach in the 1930s
was the amount of debt that governments
ended up
carrying as a result of massive
investment charges in the uk but also in
the united states for instance the new
deal so even though there was investment
in infrastructure
it was still the case that you would get
returns later on
but you would end up with higher debt
levels
now so if you fast forward to today
there is a similar concern that
debt levels were already high because
that
from the financial crisis a decade ago
had left us with a fairly highly um a
higher level um than obviously we had
seen before so you're starting from a
high level and then you're adding more
government borrowing on top of that but
where i would see perhaps um a
difference in stress or nuance is that
you know the 1930s and in fact the 1920s
which was building back from the first
world war as well as the spanish flu of
1918
uh meant that
you had this sense of you hear the term
roaring twenties that wasn't quite what
it was really um in britain but you got
the sense that there was plenty of
demand and there was this feeling that
as economies rebuild you would get a
sense
that could that there's economic growth
we're actually in a period where yes you
can also have pent-up demand and you do
see that with lockdown easing you see
the boost in economic activity but our
past decade or so in fact even further
um before that has been characterized by
a concern over slow growth
and slow
wage growth so for instance in the uk
median wages and once you adjust for
inflation hasn't increased really
for about a decade in the united states
it's hasn't increased since the 1970s
so we're actually in a period where the
expectation is growth is too slow so
this context this difference makes a
massive i think difference in thinking
about what it means to invest well also
and lots of different people have
described it in different ways on the
cusp of perhaps another digital
industrial revolution so the 21st
century world requires different
infrastructure than what the 20th
century world
had given us so all of those things
point to if government were to borrow to
invest
in say digital infrastructure in human
capital which is one of the key things
to make any digital economy work and
give us that ability to adapt then you
can generate
growth in areas that's unlikely to
address both the slow growth context
we've come out from but also position
ourselves for what the 21st century
world you know uh could mean and it's
not just services or e-commerce it also
has effects on um you know what we
produce a lot of manufactured goods you
know it's hardware as well as software
it's also affected by
the changes in technology
as well as agriculture so what that
suggests is if government can invest
in these areas and in people
and then yes debt levels will
be either already high but it could
generate growth in the coming years
that
help
help i think us recover from the
pandemic um better
so as with like mark twain said history
doesn't repeat itself but it often
rhymes so i think we can learn lessons
from what didn't work so well um back in
the interwar years and think about the
ways to um
you know to
to do it better this time
[Music]
so my book the great economist um
focused on an earlier vintage of great
economists and the only great economist
um in the book who's still alive today
is robert solo and he's working in his
90s so i start with adam smith i go
through dave ricardo germain arcanes
we've discussed and also a number of
great economists from the 20th century
they were selected on the basis that
they may not have been the first but
they were certainly the ones that came
up with the seminal model so for
instance david ricardo
came up with the theory of international
trade that still governs the way that we
think about trade even as that theory
has been developed and evolved and
changed with circumstances and you know
since he wrote it in the 19th century
so if i were to look ahead 100 years and
apply that same criteria
and again my book is focused on you know
the big picture growth uh economic
systems and development
uh the nobel prize the house prize in
economics was recently awarded to
william nordhaus for his work on um
incorporating the environment into
economic models so i would see that as
you know a b
uh issue of course for the next century
and the great economists
who
develop
ways in which we can grow in a greener
way in a way that
protects the planet
and fashions policies so that you know
we can have a great quality of life and
not just the quantity of growth i see
that as one of the major
you know
determinants of who will be great
in the next hundred years
[Music]
yeah that was actually one of the most
fun parts of writing the book um every
book um is about uh not just the ideas
but about the great economists
themselves
and you know every chapter
focuses on the ideas of a great
economist where those ideas came from
how it's rooted
in their times and then
how that applies to the way that we are
thinking about our big economic
challenges um today so i would say the
similarity that um i drew across these
great economists
was they were all very
passionate about contributing to the
debates of the day
there are um you know
economists who work and are very
focused on on their research but these
great economists i think really
contributed to policy debates so um you
know adam smith he wrote the wealth of
nations in 1776 he timed it to influence
the english position on the american
independence the war of independence in
1776
um david ricardo he lit he became an
mp and contributed to the repeal of the
coin laws which finally happened after
his death in 1846 which saw his theory
of comparative advantage
went out over the existing theories
which were around really protectionism
mercantilism that corn laws were this
protectionist piece of agricultural
legislation
and you know this continues um into the
20th century we talked about kings and
uh the work that he did i'm not just in
terms of
rethinking the role of government
in writing the economy in the short term
he was also influential in developing
the bretton woods institutions and this
is named after
the meeting in bretton woods new
hampshire which
formed the international monetary fund
the world bank so essentially the
international organizations that are
still with us um today
and then in the postwar period uh the
great economists
i think were really engaged in what i
described as a battle of ideas
so
in the postwar period there was um you
know so i'll use um joseph schumpeter as
the example he's best known for his
theory of creative destruction which
helps us understand and he studied
american massive companies at the turn
of the 20th century as well as the
mitchell stand in germany
so his theories around how firms
innovate and then this darwinian process
of creative destruction that's what he's
best known for in terms of his research
his technical work but his best known
book was probably his 1942 book and that
was called
capitalism socialism and democracy and
what he did was he contributed to that
battle of ideas of that period where you
saw this rise of marxism you saw this
rise of communism and socialist systems
and
those who believed in a capitalist or
market-based economy
like him made the case for how the
capitalist system needed reform he
described it like an engine if you don't
maintain the capitalist engine it could
stall
or certainly run badly
and that contribution to this to this
debate because remember the early 20th
century um was the rise of the soviet
union and that led to the cold war and
the postwar period china became
communists in 1949 there was a real
difference in terms of the economic
system
and he and other great economists
contributed to the um to the debates and
that eventually led to
the welfare state which we saw emerge in
the early 20th century and i think
really took root in the post-war period
which of course in this country gave us
the national health system and elsewhere
created a welfare system
and
you know that took quite a long time in
terms of changing
the capitalist system say from the days
of adam smith around factories and no
real social safety net so the changes in
ideas in the late victorian period when
there was a focus on the deserving poor
on greater philanthropy charitable
causes
all that eventually fed into welfare
state capitalism which is the system
that we have today
um
so the great economist which um you know
engaged in those issues even though i'm
taking joseph schampeter as an example
you know the um i'm pretty sure the
model in
you would consider the model that he
used in that book is probably not as
technical as the model for his creative
destruction work um however um you know
that that's not a deterrent to engaging
with the big issues and i think that's
what characterized and the great
economist and throughout history and of
course the other thing i always found
and you know hugely interesting when i
was writing the book is that they
disagreed massively so you have on the
one hand you already mentioned that
marxism but just even keynesianism
versus more free market economists like
friedrich kayak who was writing around
the same time as joseph schumpeter and
his ideas around the free market not
only influenced those behind the iron
curtain that was also linked to
thatcherism and the reagan revolution of
the 1980s so you have this battle of
ideas um
you know even between economists who are
all working generally towards reforming
the market-based economy the capitalist
system but from very different
approaches
and you know history proves them right
for a period wrong for a period and
we're still looking at um you know what
has uh what what has worked and what
needs uh adaptation and that's where you
know i sort of conclude the book which
is looking you know ahead at some of
these issues some of which we've already
touched upon and um
and thinking about how we can learn
lessons from what these great economists
and you know went through and apply it
to today but you know we're able to to
pick and choose because they've left
such a rich
legacy the other thing i would say is
you know um the biographies are probably
some of my favorite parts of writing the
book because they just led such hugely
interesting lives you know divorces
affairs um
ambition uh you know
it just it you know had it all
you know um so the great accounts are
hugely interesting people um as well as
having made a massive impact on you know
on the world
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of arts
and ideas
at iai tv
you